I'd say in the last
few years
my feeling about the United States
has
changed
and it's changed in a somber way for
most of my life
for most of my life
I've been in the optimistic camp with
respect to my view of American race
relations
you know the the optimistic camp that
was the camp that's the camp that
believes We Shall Overcome
uh that's that's Martin Luther King's
camp I mean Martin Luther King you know
Martin Luther King you know hours before
he's killed I've been to the Mountaintop
I might not get there with you
but I've glimpsed the Promised Land
that optimism
uh Frederick Douglass would be in that
would be in that tradition
um there would be other people
uh wonderful good people who would be in
that tradition would you start to
interrupt putting the pessimist account
would you put Malcolm X in them oh and
the pessimistic Camp the pessimistic
Camp is the more interesting campaign I
mean ideological I mean it is it's the
more interesting camp yeah because in
the pessimistic Camp you have I mean if
I was going to list some of my
pessimists
pessimist number one Thomas Jefferson
Thomas Jefferson the author you know
principal author Declaration of
Independence he was also the author of
notes on the state of Virginia
and he said in notes on the state of
Virginia
basically we shall not overcome
uh he talked to he said you know
um the black people
will always know
that their forebears were enslaved
and they will always be resentful of
that always be aggrieved by that
Jefferson did not think that we would
ever have in the United States a
multi-racial democracy
he was very critical of slavery now he
was a hypocrite he had slaves he sold
slaves
he was terrible in that way but he did
understand that slavery was horrible
but
he did not want he he all but he he did
not want to free the slaves for a
variety of reasons but in one reason was
because he thought that it would be
impossible to have a society in which
blacks and whites
were
equal neighbors he was thoroughly
pessimistic another pessimist Alexis de
tocqueville
thoroughly pessimistic
so who were some of the other pessimists
Abraham Lincoln
pessimistic that's why he was so
interested in colonization he basically
said you know I don't like slavery but
blacks and whites are not going to be
able to share the United States maybe
the best we can do is just you know put
blacks ship black someplace else can you
elaborate on that I I think people would
be surprised to hear oh yeah you will
put Abraham Lincoln in the pessimist
camp Oh Abraham Lincoln's thoroughly
pessimistic he was like he he believed
he was Auntie he he was anti-slavery
but he did not believe that blacks and
whites would be able to share the United
States together
and he was always very interested
therefore in colonization
even after the even during the Civil War
he was interested in you know maybe
maybe maybe all black people would all
black people be interested in maybe
going to Panama would they be interested
in going someplace else because you know
Lincoln was aware of how racist white
people were including himself
and he did not think that black people
and white people would be able to share
the United States
now there's the black nationalist
tradition you mentioned Malcolm Maxwell
before Malcolm X you know Marcus Garvey
um my father
my father was a thorough going pessimist
his view was a the United States was
born as a white man's country it's going
to remain a white man's country
uh and that's the way it is he was
thoroughly pessimistic